avant que johanna ne viennent sur ce
plateau petit détour par les salles
obscures mercredi jour des sorties ciné
les nouveaux films à l'affiché
vous êtes allé les voir qu'en
pensez-vous micro-trottoir d'elodie -
prince charmant c'est très sympa et
c'est un bon film allait à voir et c'est
magnifique
je trouve ça très bien mais il est très
bien par l'amour de mariage bat que
c'était très sympathique comme film
c'est plaisant à voir les acteurs zulia
le comédie légère
ça parle d'amour
se remettre en question si c'est pas un
chat dehors
non mais on ça distrait mais c'est pas
extraordinaire
c'est pas genre de films qui me plaît
ses portes
mais enfin ça fait passer le temps bon
c'est un film sympa et rigolo on passe
un bon petit moment c'est bien marrant
va très très bien
franchement bon scénario et les musiques
sont franchement bien ouais c'est un
super bon film rigole ouais c'est bien
c'est sympa comme comme thème et tous et
c'est bien exploités je pense à la
chronique culture comme chaque mercredi
johanna vous êtes venu avec trois
invités ce soir oui j'ai de la chance on
est bien entouré ce soir alors j c
auteur compositeur interprète et
guitariste
vous êtes venu avec un autre guitariste
à côté de moi jérôme jérôme gauthier et
puis en face de moi masse vous êtes
rappeur vous sortez un nouvel album
l'album s'appelle moi et j'entends
direct dans le vif du sujet pourquoi ce
titre
et ma peur pourquoi ce titre parce que
en fait bon déjà c'est le titre d'un
morceau qui figure dans l'album et on
traverse à travers son morceau j'ai
voulu développer ce que le mot - voulait
dire pour moi
donc voilà c'est comment dire c'est de
se trouver en fait trouvé sa voie et
c'est de s'affirmer et puis faire des
choses qu'on aime donc voilà il est cité
comme j'étais un peu dans cette
direction là je pensais que c'était le
titre le plus approprié pour l'album et
en même temps ils refirent jeu reflète
plusieurs facettes de ma personnalité
et donc voilà c'est un album qui parle
de moi est un peu votre parcours aussi
parce qu'à des morceaux plus anciens les
actes commis exactement dans quel et
morceaux qui ont plus de 5 ans d'âge
j'ai voulu que ces morceaux la soie dans
l'album et voilà des morceaux comme
un morceau qui s'appelle pour ceux où je
parle de mes parents je fais un petit
clin d'oeil je leur dis merci pour ce
qu'ils ont fait de moi et voilà morceau
qui s'appelle marraine pour celle qui
partage la vie depuis pas mal de temps
donc c'est des sujets un peu qu'on
retrouve pas forcément dans le rap mais
que j'ai envie de rester difficile
d'imposer ce genre de thématique de ce
livre est de parler de soi dans le
milieu du rap sur ces thématiques bah
c'est pas forcément on fait parce que
quelque part l'europe simple reflet une
personnalité et un prêt tout dépends
d'eads et de nos choix personnel et
moins
comme jeu
j'étais un peu plus enfin pas enfermés
mais j'avais vraiment besoin de me
retrouver et donc forcément les thèmes
que j'allais à bord d aller dans ce sens
sont en fait vous n'avez pas été freiné
sur l'écriture des morceaux justement
vous dire non ça je peux quand même pas
le dire sur moi j'ai pas envie de parler
de ça ça ça m'appartient ses personnels
vous avez réussi à me libérer ouais j'ai
réussi à me livrer et en même temps il
en même temps j'ai ce qui m'a plu c'est
quand je faisais des concerts j'ai
justement j'avais l'impression que pour
les autres c'est un peu la même chose
donc du coup c'était plus simple donc
quelque part c'est pas vraiment c'est
pas juste un album qui parle de moins
c'est un album qui paraît un peu tout le
monde et aux autres à travers vous voilà
c'est ça justement parle d autres enfin
regarder un clip on voit beaucoup de
visages c'est votre chanson fais un voeu
on va voir un extrait tout de suite et
on en reparle après pas de problème
moyer dans le guidon cela sur fichu mais
jamal dont il fut maire r les moutons
bis et soumet avancé sous le piano ne
pas renoncer même confins des mots se
montrer même qu'on croit les mots de
voix sont faits pour qu'il ira on dit
pousser les parties durent de procéder
par étapes
ici rien défaut est ce qui paraît qui
s'éclaire vue creuser l'écart et or en
billons match comme étant observé en
change de lever le camp non vérifiées at
on envie de lever le camp
aussi que je ne sais pas
malheur à tous
massa ça fait une dizaine d'années que
vous vivez enfin presque dix ans
j'exagère presque deux ans dans les
yvelines et à l'équipe il a été tourné à
paris notamment on a vu dans d'autres
villes dont la celle-saint-cloud aussi
on voit pas mal de portraits de
personnes ça fait comme ça au texte de
la chanson c'est ça c'était juste pour
dire que quelque part le thé que nous
concernait pas seulement et que voilà
c'est des choses en fait c'est des
passages à huit camps que l'on rencontre
et ça peu fait ça parle à plusieurs
personnes en fait c'est à dire que c'est
un thème peu je dirais universel et puis
voilà c'est un peu les les moments fin
conserva pain et voilà garde espoir
exode se battre dans la vie pour avancer
le message reprendre le souffle c'est
reparti est ce que c'est important la
vidéo dans le monde du rap c'est un
moyen de s'exprimer de se faire
connaître mais peut-être que dans
d'autres courants musicaux
c'est très important effectivement
pour quelle raison je saurai vous dire
mon tout cas ça a pris une grande place
en tout cas dans le milieu du rap est
effectivement pour par exemple pour mon
projet je suis à peu près à deux
semaines de la sortie de mon album et à
dia 3 3 vidéos qui tournent donc
effectivement se fait beaucoup
et donc c'est un fonds investi en faire
pas mal de choses à ce niveau là mais
nous enfin les personnes qui nous
écoutent en général ont besoin de
l'image en voir un peu justement l'homme
le message qu'on veut véhiculer le
mettre en images ce qu'on a voulu passer
comme message est très présent et
justement réagissez vous fait pas du
tout le même style de musique on va
l'entendre tout à l'heure mais justement
c'est cette idée de l'image qui est
important de véritablement pour pour le
rap ça l'est aussi sur notre courant
plus sur le rock aussi - je crois que
c'est pas une question de courant c'est
une question aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'avoir un contenu vidéo visuel vous y
faites attention vous aussi on travaille
aussi en parallèle sur tout ce qui est
clip vidéo pour l'instant c'est en
projet je suis pas encore dessus mais
effectivement c'est quelque chose de
très important du aujourd'hui les
artistes c'est un passage obligé
avec internet forcément d'ailleurs
internet vous en pensez quoi alors pas
ce que vaut aveu mais on peut les
trouver à tous les deux sur sur internet
en téléchargement légal bien sûr on
précise et par rapport à virgin voilà
qui est bon là on connaît sa situation
difficile en ce moment qu'est ce que
vous pensez vous en tant qu'artiste de 2
à 7 cette habitude voilà que les gens
ont prise de peut-être téléchargé comme
ça sur internet pour vous en tout cas ça
vous facilite la vie dans votre carrière
ou ça peut être aussi un frein comment
vous percevez les choses moi je pensais
c'est un formidable vecteur pour pouvoir
se faire connaître de faire diffuser sa
musique pour avoir accès au public
après c'est évident pour certains
artistes qui sont confirmées votre nom
pour quand il essaie de vendre leurs
disques dès que les dix sont échangées
sur le web c'est plus compliqué pour je
partage le même avis effectivement c'est
un peu plus c'est plus simple et
puissant pour nous autres c'est à dire
que voir même pour avoir un distributeur
distributeurs on n'est pas à l'heure
actuelle n'est pas forcément obligé
obligé d'en avoir un donc ça simplifie
pas mal de choses effectivement à côté
de ça c'est aussi plus difficile de
pouvoir gagner de l'argent donc c'est
pas évident donc pour se lancer c'est
quand même plus pratique justement va
parler de vos débuts masse vous avez
commencé à écrire des textes après le
lycée et vous avez été très vite repéré
par joeystarr c'est pas mal ça comment
vous avez fait je ne sais pas en fait
j'ai commencé au lycée est en fait c'est
à la sortie du lycée en classe de
terminale ou enfin à l'époque et pas mal
de on faisait pas mal de mixer c'était
des petites casses et où on enregistrait
des morceaux et comme dépendent des mots
un petit peu c'est un peu ça sauf que là
pour la plupart cédés personnes
confirmées kiki qui la faisait parce
qu'il fallait quand même à l'époque
avoir des moyens parce que font un petit
studio ou soit enfin quelque chose pour
enregistrer à l'époque ce n'était pas
donné
et du coup même justement les ris que de
killer qui cdd mixte et il y avait
à l'époque didier pense qu'à enfin des
grands didier en tout cas pour l'époque
et donc voilà on m'a rien à nu qui m'a
appelé pour participer à une mixte et
j'en ai fait une en effet deux en effet
3 et le bouche à oreille a fonctionné
par chance est venue aux oreilles et de
joey starr dj ce pont qu'à l'époque
et voilà ils ont voulu me rencontrer ça
s'est fait naturellement parce qu'ils
préparaient une compilation bio c'est ce
volume 1 des gens ont apprécié mon
travail est un soin entre en week-end
passé une bonne carte de visite ou alors
est-ce que du coup vous avez un peu
l'image du bad boy joey starr qui est
ntm en tout cas qu'ils font en tout cas
au nom à l'époque je pense que c'était
vraiment une bonne carte de visite parce
que j'ai pu faire pas mal de choses des
bo de films comme yamakasi ils ont
participé à différents albums donc à
l'époque je pense que c'était vraiment
une bonne chose pour la paraplégie
exemple on en discute encore je pense
que c'est quelque chose de positif parce
que j'ai beaucoup appris justement avec
son label met en parallèle c'est que
voilà il a un
beaucoup de charisme et donc forcément
pour faire sa place il existait voilà
c'est pas forcément évident c'est à dire
que même si on fait le travail qu'il
faut bas les gens ont tendance au départ
plus envie de discuter avec lui et enfin
de voir les choses avec lui donc on est
un peu noyé dans son ouvrage avait
réussi à imposer la vôtre après et dans
votre carrière vous ne vous limitez pas
au rap vous ouvrez aussi à d'autres
styles musicaux
par exemple le rock la soul ça pour vous
c'est ça un atout ça vous permet de
toucher un public plus large
merci de vous ouvrir peut-être vous
détacher d'une image de rappeur
dès qu'il déniche justement on fait dix
ans que l'on parte en justement du label
bio ss je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais pas enfin été jetés ouvert à
d'autres à d'autres musiques entre
guillemets donc
voilà je regardais les clips à l'époque
j'ai vu le clip de silmarils c'était
court vite c'est un peu un peu des
malades ces mecs là enfin bref j'ai
cherché à les rencontrer on s'est vus et
du coup on a fait un mort c'est ensemble
qu'ils s'appellent animal qui est sur
leur dernier album est donc voilà donc
ça j'ai pu côtoyer le milieu du rock par
leur intermédiaire on a fait des scènes
on a fait le bataclan on a fait un
nouveau casino pas mal de dates avec eux
et donc voilà j'ai c'est là aussi j'ai
commencé à jouer avec des musiciens sur
scène donc j'ai apprécié ce boulot là et
puis voilà mais la soul c'était un peu
après new de la danse aussi j'ai fait un
clash rap danseurs enfin pas j'ai voulu
voir ce qui se passait ailleurs mains
sont restés avec nous on va continuer à
parler musique on change d'univers
charles berling
oui parce que vous savez que chantait
charles berling est en tout cas il
passera bois d'arcy le samedi 19 janvier
et nous l'avions rencontré il ya
quelques semaines dans sa résidence à la
grange de la tramblais on le connaissait
acteurs mais pas encore chanteur charles
berling continue de monter sur scène
mais il est désormais accompagné de
musiciens la chanson une envie à ce
nouvel pour l'artiste ça fait une
dizaine d'années que j'ai recommencé à
ma passion avec la chanson que je dis
recommencer parce que au fond quand
j'avais entre 14 et 20 ans quand j'ai
commencé ce métier au lycée
dumont-d'urville d'ailleurs à toulon et
bien je faisais du théâtre du cinéma en
faisant des films super 8 et de la
chanson et
les coptes
mais m
de ses chansons charles berling écrit
les paroles
un moyen pour lui de raconter mon
histoire des mots posés sur le papier et
mise en musique par des professionnels
tels que robert le gall ou encore yvan
cassar il ya une dizaine d'années je me
suis remis à écrire beaucoup de paroles
de chansons et après j'ai démontré des
musiciens qui semble-t-il est mêlé les
paroles puisqu'ils ont écrit des
musiques dont bertrand burgalat carla
bruni philippe jacot fabien kaen et
freddy qu est là et j'en passe
le résultat sur scène et de la chanson
française kiki qu'un peu la pêche quoi
voilà c'est ça que j'adore oui bah moi
si je vais sur scène c'est pas pour
m'endormir ou endormir les gens
le public pourra découvrir le jeune
chanteur à bois d'arcy à la grange de la
tramblais samedi 19 janvier à 20h30
on a eu la chance de répéter d'abord une
résidence ici pendant cela avec des
moyens techniques et d
des gens très sympathiques qui nous
accueille la salle est très bien et en
plus il a une bonne acoustique comme on
est content du sont ceux qui aiment la
chanson française qui ont envie de
découvrir jeune chanteur un mari qui
viennent
je fume
en fait très bien la chorégraphie je
vois les oui j'ai reçu j'ai pu voir et
revoir comme c'est un petit coup de main
vous en pensez-quoi jc jérôme vous avez
vous guitare l'a déjà prête
le un petit peu la prestation de charles
berling en tant que chanteur ça vous
inspire
ce furent pas forcément mais c'est très
bien qu'il ya de la place pour tout le
monde alors en tout cas vous sortez vos
si un nouvel album baptisé tenir le coup
c'est votre album le plus abouti on va
dire vous êtes vous écrivait des textes
vous composé la mélodie vous chantez
aussi sur cet album
et là vous êtes accompagné donc 2 jérôme
un autre guitariste
vous avez vu l'état puisque vous avez
vous joué un petit un petit morceau tout
à l'heure tu puisses tu rigole mais
avant qu'on découvre un petit peu quel
est votre votre univers musical alors
univers gilles carle est liée
principalement à la base dans le rock
plutôt le sixties seventies et je me
suis un peu inspirée de ses sonorités la
de ces musiques là pour faire un prêt
des choses sont un peu plus variété rock
pop avec toujours des sonorités qui
restent
ce que j'aime dans le rock est un peu un
peu le blues de temps en temps aussi aux
influences c'est otis redding par
exemple où ça en fait partie mais il
yad'autres d'autres musiciens comme ça
qui vous ont marqués qui dispensent et
surtout des gens qui m'ont donné envie
de chanter les gens comme commandes
stewart
je les ai des rolling stones enfin tous
et tous ces grands groupes de rock
pour la france il ya john l idée pour
alors jérôme vous connaissez très bien j
c'est tout l'état parce que ce qu'on
peut me raconter comment vous êtes connu
ça c'est assez sympa comme histoire je
cherchais un prof de guitare et en fait
il m'a donné mon premier cours de
guitare je vais avoir jeu pas très haut
c'est ça et donc maintenant jouer
ensemble voilà régulièrement
régulièrement
alors est ce qu'on peut entendre ce que
ça donne vous allez nous jouer le
morceau pour te dire vous écoute
trop de temps j'avais su
de jean marc lassus
honteux là je vais
à
faire
je ne suis qu'à me
c'est très peu
qui sait
turquie saint pée
je
des refuges
des images d'un jeu pas sûr
autant dire que je l'aimais
contre la
à
toi
que je la soutiens
c
seul
qui s'appelait
bon
perdu
enfin
c
peut-être
m
qui dit
ça va
on n'est pas nombreux mais n'étaient pas
nombreux mais c'est ce qu'on dit dans
ces cas là il manque le public toujours
alors on va se retrouver en concert à
l'utopia c'est un club privé sur paris
mais on peut quand même venir vous voir
en passant par facebook c'est ça on va
sur facebook on vous dira venir vous
voir c'est un message avec un bon c'est
donc ce titre on peut le retrouver sur
l'album soul album et dans cette version
alors avec d'autres non non c'est une
version qui est complètement différente
on doit adapter la configuration de
guitare c'est une version qui est
beaucoup plus un peu pop comme ça au
départ et qui après devient très rock
avec des guitares électriques batteries
c'est complètement différent où j'invite
activement les gens allaient coûter le
titre dans sa version originale sur
internet aux voiles house procurer
l'album aussi de tenir le coup donc
qu'on peut récupérer sur internet
et pareil pour mas votre album mois
également disponible sur internet
j'ai donc sur mon site internet jc peau
comme très bien normalement je pense
qu'il a dû apparaître cette affiche et
moi c'est formidable
merci à tous les trois merci johanna
dans un instant on va écouter le des
saint-quentinois comme chaque soir au
cours de ce mois de janvier on va
écouter leurs voeux 2013 mais pour
terminer on a deux artistes avec deux
univers différents et pourquoi pas leur
demander
le premier couplet de fait un voeu par
exemple de masse avec accompagnement à
la guitare je n'avais pas parlé aux
coulisses a envoyé j'étais ici en
plateau et voilà c'est pour la caméra
alors on va laisser le jex comme vous
voulez le texte que vous voulez
accompagné à la guitare
j'essaie de démarrer puis ça sera pour
terminer avec les saint quentinois juste
après je souhaite sur nos textes moi qui
en suis peut-être sont plus là nous
envoie hockey dire moi c'est un choix
les hémois change c'est ainsi l'ange se
met à son le malien site c'est étrange
et si on le compare un site ici pour
surfer on est seul mois une syllabe un
seul cette fausse mettront celle d'hier
non ils ont et s'ils ont eu ces langages
le potiron ils ont continué on lille en
moi te fait vivre
toro libre de vie c'est vivre son havre
de paix même si opel de vie de skins art
de dire moi mais xavi le laisser outre
ou plus fatigué advint dire moi c'est ce
que je suis
as-tu au ciel mon essence je sais que tu
as aimé vivre et suisse en ciel
vivre est essentielle vivre est
essentiel c'est moi même comme ça 6
merci magie c'est un fait inédit alors
sur le plateau bravo à tous les trois
étaient vraiment pas prévu
merci beaucoup aux pas sauvé des saint
quentinois que vous souhaiter pour 2013
vos réponses 2013 qu'il y ait la paix
dans le monde
et puis qu'il y ait moins de malheureux
la santé premier la santé on est tous
malades à la maison depuis plusieurs
mois donc la santé je cherche une bonne
année à tous cheminer et voilà qu'il
réussit dans leur vie voilà je souhaiter
la bonne année à vous sentez avoir
beaucoup d'argent
les enfants 117,8 pour aujourd'hui
rendez vous demain jeudi 18h en direct
pour une nouvelle édition programme
débats autour du mariage pour tous alors
que la question de la procréation
médicale assistée ne fera pas partie du
projet de loi l'annoncé a été faite
aujourd'hui en plateau je recevrai des
responsables d'associations des
responsables politiques
également vous entendrez des témoignages
et les analysent également d'un avocat
spécialisé dans le droit de la famille
page spéciale mariage pour tous alors
que le 13 janvier ce timbre à la
manifestation pour tous contre ce projet
de loi ce sera à paris rendez vous pour
le 7 8 sur tous les fils excellente
soirée allemand